(dramatic music)
- Welcome to This
Is Not Happening.
I'm your host Roy Wood Jr.
- Uh-oh.
- Pow.
- I'll kil everybody.
- What?
- Just listen to
the fucking store.
- Whoa is this crazy?
- I have no idea but it's
fucking fun man, I know that.
(cheers and applause)
- Your man Ari Shafir was
kind enough to hand over
the reins to me, what
you will see tonight
is fucking good
ass story telling.
- And she starts to go
like a fucking horse
in to my face.
- Tonight we are telling
true stories about shame,
moms, wasted, filth,
dads, romance, nightmares,
strange lands, famous, combat.
(shouts)
- I don't know if you guys
have ever cock blocked
a rapist before.
- Fuck that I own
self insurance.
- Well that's, just you
know, pretty bullshit.
(audience laughs)
- The next 18
messages on my phone
were dudes really
trying hard to fuck me.
- All the signs were
there, you know,
she was distant, she wasn't
returning my phone calls
as quickly as she used to,
her pussy tasted like dick.
- You think you've
hit rock bottom.
- I just stared into the
eye of my boyfriend's
ex-girlfriend's butt hole.
- (imitates gun) Alright.
- So I got a 45 pointed right
in the middle of my chest.
- And I'm like oh fuck, I'm
gonna get shot in Arizona.
- You can hear jokes anywhere,
motherfuckers coming up here
to tell you stuff that's
gonna get them uninvited
from thanksgiving.
(groans)
- So in that moment I made
the decision, I'm like,
that's it, I'm gonna
fucking kill my dad.
- It's terrible that someone's
laughing at that part.
(laughs)
- You're brilliant.
- If I snorkeled on molly
with Donald Trump,
I would be up here right now
being like you don't know him
like I do.
- Oh by the way,
I fucked a midget.
- I guess the president figured
that would be a good
business competition.
(audience laughs)
- Oh shit, crackers
are dead to me.
- What do they put
in it, cigarettes?
(roars)
- So now this dudes on top of
me trying to bite my face off.
- Ah you god damned baby.
- When you hit somebody
that's trying to kill you
oh it feels great.
- Hey for old times sake,
let's just drive to Mexico
and commit a federal crime.
- Oh hey guys, this
ain't enough to show you
that there's
something very wrong.
(intense music)
- And that's how I became
the host of the new season
of This Is Not Happening.
(cheers and applause)